PROFESSOR: Co-teaching
with Srini,
Professor Srinivas Devadas
is really a lot of fun.
We've taught before.
We taught the 6006
that's on OCW together.
And Srini is I would say one
of the most humorous professors
that I know at MIT.
So it's really a lot of
fun to teach with him.
And I mean, sometimes
it's like a comedy
routine in his lectures.
And I like to do that too in
lectures, tell lots of jokes
and play together.
So it's really nice
working together.
We have a good dynamic.
We're both super
flexible, like, oh, I
need you to cover this lecture.
Oh, no problem, I
love that stuff.
In fact, we were both kind
of fighting over which
lectures we wanted to teach.
Because I was
like, I really want
to teach this-- no,
no, I taught it.
I really want to
teach it this time.
So that's a nice
dynamic to have.
It's not like oh, you
taught one too few lectures,
it's not balanced.
Totally not like that.
And both in 6006 and
6046, in the last lecture
we do a kind of
actual comedy routine
where we're somehow
fighting each other.
It's all in good humor,
and it's pretty fun.
The students really like it.
He's also-- in both classes
he has creative ideas
on how to reward students
for answering questions.
So in 6006, we were in a
relatively uncomfortable
lecture hall.
And so we had these pillows
that we had custom printed
and had the name of the
class and a little Rubik's
cube on it.
And so if anyone ever
answered a question in class
or asked a good
question, then we
would throw them a pillow,
kind of like a Frisbee.
And so for 6046,
Srini was like, you
know what we have to do this
time is get actual Frisbees.
And so we got these blue
and purple Frisbees,
also custom printed
with the class number
and a little diagram that is
in lecture 20 or something.
And so whenever anyone asked
or answered a question,
we would throw them a Frisbee.
We'd make jokes about
whether blue was better,
or purple was better.
There was no better.
It was just--
So this was tough for me,
because I had to really learn
how to throw Frisbees.
But I think by the end of the
semester, I got pretty good.